that's me can you buzz me in
good for you
[Music]
the three of you think you have
extraordinary gifts like something out
of a comic document I've developed an
effective treatment for this disorder
the light will force a different
identity to take off step away from the
controls now can't beat the beat so
you're not gonna shake my hand and let
me walk out of here
[Music]
there were dragons when I was a boy
where they went
only a few know our story changed the
world forever we have to fight for their
freedom
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't nothing without your dragon
as you and me bud always
[Music]
so scrolls are the bad guys
and you're a tree a race of noble boys
heroes noble warrior heroes the small
just a beginning
I'm not gonna fight your war
[Music]
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
[Music]
say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your name
sir sure Sam wait for you
sigh okay Shazam
you know I don't think that's gonna buff
out your bun charge your phone charge
he'll be like a bad guy right
I will prove you're dead sorry about
your window yeah welcome for not getting
robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero
[Music]
thanos did exactly what he said he was
gonna do
he wiped out 50% of all living creatures
this is the fight of our lives this is
gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I
don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
was fall
[Music]
Oh
here's that good morning New York City
[Music]
what are you doing what's it look like
I'm doing
I'm doing superhero stuff
[Music]
castle
and everywhere
I looked at class up way
but now
we block
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey somebody get in before coaching I am
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]